[Music]
hello and welcome to a very special
sickie pants version of dear Hank and
John Thor's I prefer to think of a dear
Jonah
oh it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers who have independently
contracted rhinoviruses answer your
questions give you dubious advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon John I am sick I
barely crawled out of bed to come here
to be honest with you I I woke up tried
to get the kids ready for school and
then Sarah came downstairs and she was
like you should just go back to bed and
I went back to bed and I woke up and
then it was now yeah this morning I said
to Catherine I Orin woke up he woke up
he got sort of like he's sitting up and
like sort of standing and then he
tripped over his sleep sack and fell and
whacked his head on the crib and so he's
just like screaming and I was like we
have a camera in there and we can rewind
it and watch this all happen which is
just great he does it three times he
hits his and and like I'm like
Katherine's like cuz I take care of
Lauren in the mornings and Catherine is
like okay well why are you still laying
there and I'm like can you do it yeah
and so she did it and that was very nice
I mean it every time I'm sick I think to
myself god bless single parents yeah
they're now they're doing incredible
work do not understand if you have a
single parent give them a hug if you are
a single parent here's is a hug from us
it's non physical my favorite kind of
hug yeah especially when you're not
feeling very well here coming for a big
ol Piracy hug I got so many different
microorganisms on my hands and face Oh
ma'am dark tone I'd be interesting this
will be interesting and to pull out I
hope that I hope we do it well did you
happen to come across a short poem this
week John a short a short poem was
suggested to us actually by Annie who
was suggesting a poem by professor
emeritus Ken Michalowski of her alma
mater the University of Michigan
mystery number two it's called mystery
number two ten in the dining room one
falls in the soup poisoned you were the
host what do you do it's good it's good
it's a comedy about death you we don't
get enough of those around here so
that's that was that was a welcome
change of pace Thank You Annie all right
thank you John for your lovely reading
and our first question that's gonna come
to you from cat who asks dear Hank and
John space is a vacuum which means that
sound doesn't travel which is where we
get the classic line in space no one can
hear you scream by that logic if aliens
exist I'm assuming they would spend most
of their time in space and wouldn't be
able to hear anything so would they
communicate using sign language what is
that why the record we launched into
space has gone unanswered like first
they have to have a record player them
and dubious answers greatly appreciated
KITT can't know it again I think that
mostly we're not we don't expect to find
the aliens living in space expect to
find them maybe living in space ships in
space but also potentially on other
planets there is a really really
wonderful so there's this this Twitter
that's called shoot I forgot what it's
called great this is already a high
quality podcasting entertainment for the
people I can't do this the feeling out
of my throat no matter what I do it's a
very good comic from this is a Twitter
account called a small fiction and just
basically tries to tell a story inside
of a tweet and that the tweet is Oracle
are we alone in the universe
and then the Oracle says yes and then
the little girl says so there's other
life out and then the little girl says
so there's no other life out there and
then the Oracle says there is there
alone too which is probably the truth
right I mean there is probably life out
there and
yeah probably never have any kind of
contact with it and that they will
probably and like not only will we never
have any kind of contact with any of the
life out there all of the life out there
will probably have never have any
contact with each other either there
there are weird reasons why this might
be because like in areas where there are
lots of stars that are close together
it's actually less likely for life to
form in those places because there's so
much high-energy radiation because it
might be closer to the center of the
galaxy where there's a lot of stars
we're quite far out and in the center of
the galaxy there's a lot more
high-energy stuff happening but also in
stellar formation areas there's a lot
more like energy that you know might
might be contrary to the formation of
complicated molecules so they're like
you know it's a big universe or they're
probably there probably is life out
there that knows about other life which
is really cool and like that's a nice
thing to think about but for the most
part probably like the the default is
that other life in the universe is also
alone and will be alone forever
it's a I love it I love it but also also
that life probably exists inside of a
soup of gases or or liquids that can
transfer sound waves so they probably do
have some kind of way to talk though I
would not expect they have a way to play
a record but maybe you never know you
never know this next question comes from
Jesse writes Dear John and Hank I'm a
middle school teacher first off Jess I
just want to pause from your question
and say thank you thank you for being a
middle school teacher I was so terrible
to my middle school teachers but they
were so kind to me so irrationally kind
so thank you on behalf of all of your
terrible annoying students one of my
students gave me a gift card to the
local movie theater with the note to see
Star Wars on it
I have often shared my love of Star Wars
with my students and have even gone so
far as to dress up in Star Wars costumes
and work Star Wars into my lesson plans
got that I mean that is a cool teacher
the issue I have already seen Star Wars
the last Jedi four times and I plan to
see it again with my friends from
college later this month for a total of
five times do I go see Star Wars again
for a total of six times or can I go see
a different movie
with the gift card that was designated
for Star Wars Han shot first Jess I mean
you have way too much respect for your
students way I would just stand out
front of the movie theater and be like
free Star Wars ticket well no it's not
even that if car Jess can see whatever
movie she wants it's not like that she's
gonna go up to the counter and gonna be
like I'd like to use this gift card to
see I don't know I Tania or Lady Bird
and they're gonna be like oh I'm sorry
that gift cards only good for Star Wars
no the movie theater doesn't care what
movie you see go see Lady Bird it's
great uh also it seems to me this year
about to go see Star Wars again why
don't you use it for going out with your
friend I think I think she probably
already bought the ticket like
problematic sort of to ticket online
already like specific spot I think one
hundred percent this is a great great
opportunity to go see Lady Bird which I
loved by the way Hank I I don't usually
like to brag about this although I think
I do bring it up on the podcast every
year but we get most of the Oscar
contenders mailed to our house because
many years ago I was made to join a
union and at the time I was very
resentful but it turns out to have been
a really great investment and yeah so we
got to see I've gotten to see a bunch of
the Award candidate movies this year and
I think lady I honestly think Lady Bird
is my favorite I have not seen it I have
not seen any movies except for Star Wars
and I believe that I watched meet me in
st. Louis
and guardians of the galaxy - so far
this year well well that is that's an
interesting list you might be the only
person who's hit that particular
trifecta I mean I mean certainly I am
the only person who's watched only those
so yeah going outside of the house is
hard and John doesn't send me his
screeners because I can't just in case
the Writers Guild is listening I would
never share my screen errs our biggest
are the biggest segment of our audience
the Writers Guild of America
Oh God i I think I I had like a slight
fever this morning and I I took Advil
and I think it's wearing off I just want
to give you a personal update can we can
we answer another question yeah John
let's do that this next question comes
from Maria who asks dear Hank and John
I'm a 16 year old Italian girl and my
father works abroad because of this I
often have to take planes and travel on
my own to go visit him however when I do
so I often would receive a lot of
unwanted attention from adult men ever
from my peers or kind ladies just old
men they often try to talk to me asking
me why such a young ladies traveling by
herself where I'm going and so on I try
not to be rude to these people but these
situations make me uncomfortable and
they keep happening how should I deal
with this I actually have good good
advice well I don't have to create
advice but I have advice all I've got is
all I've got his headphones never take
your headphones out oh that is my advice
ok Maria before you get on the plane
put earbuds in your ear you don't
actually have to listen to anything I
don't usually listen to anything but
this is what I'll tell you what I do
before I get on the plane
I put earbuds in my ears actually I do
this the moment I arrived at the airport
uh-huh perfectly honest of you I arrived
at the airport
I put earbuds in my ear I go through all
of the usual processes and I find that
people talk much less to me when I have
earbuds in my ear even though I'm not
listening to anything and I can hear
everything they say and I can answer
them in a normal voice so I don't like
respond to them by shouting so hopefully
I'm not being overly you're not even
you're not even listening to your
podcast I will say John you cannot have
earbuds in your ears if you're gonna
speak to a service employee that's like
I'm out I'm out if that's your strategy
because if I'm gonna talk to that like
the TSA guy and he's gonna give me like
I'm gonna I have to like say I'm a
normal person and I'm having an
interaction with a normal person like we
we are required to interact and so I'm
taking my headphones out and then they
go right back in afterwards ok you do it
your way you could do it you could do it
whichever way you want but that is that
is my sincerest recommendation I
Hank if I told the story on the podcast
before about that the worst thing that
ever happened to me in my whole life I
mean I don't I don't know I don't know
alright so you do tend to to exaggerate
so I'm not sure which which worst thing
this is this isn't the worst thing that
ever happened to me in my entire life
but it was really really bad so one time
I was on a three hour and ten minutes
flight and I had the usual strategy I
put my earbuds in before boarding the
flight I handed over my boarding pass I
boarded the plane i sat down in my seat
I put my backpack underneath the seat
and I and I actually then started to
actually listen to music because the
person next to me kept looking at me and
I was like maybe they need to hear sound
coming out of my earbuds for me to
effectively communicate that I'm I'm not
an airplane talker because I'm a very
nervous person I was gonna say a nervous
flier but that actually would be
understating the matter pretty
significantly and and this person who is
sitting next to me just as the plane
began to taxi reached over and touched
my ear and pulled pulled the earbud out
of my ear oh my god I can't like wet
like the feeling of my ear of an earbud
being removed even if it's like because
it got caught on some pho it's always a
bad way though worst feelings that I
experienced regular well and you can
imagine have it done to me by another
person who you don't know who you've
never spoken to actually and I assume I
assume that this person had an emergency
to convey to you uh yeah hi I'm about to
poo in my pail or there's a fire on the
plane wasn't for the lady in front of us
just her head exploded you know
something that like you need to know no
it wasn't any of those things it was
that they were a very nervous flier and
would I talk to them oh that's kind of
sad um and I was like
yeah yes of course
so Maria you may find yourself in a
situation where a stranger pulls the
earbud out of your ear but in that case
they're either going to say I am a
nervous flier the person in front of
yous head is exploded or third option
they're going to say anything else in
which case you're going to just put the
earbud right back in yeah I mean you in
in situations like this that like there
are gonna be guys who don't understand
that like they're like but um I'm not
here to harass you but what they don't
understand is like for for you there's
no way to tell and once you're listening
to the harassment it's very difficult to
go back to your life and not be like I
need to be like reassigned and so like
you want to cut that off at the
beginning which is absolutely fine and
you are an autonomous person who has
been sat in a chair next to another
person and that does not mean that you
have to talk to them you have been
assigned this place next to a stranger
and that comes with no rights and
responsibilities to interact with them
and so it is it's some it is it
definitely if you are wearing headphones
it is absolutely rude for someone to
interrupt that and if they don't get
that it is not rude for you to in reply
not interact with them yeah no you yeah
I strongly agree with you Hank and now
I'm now I'm getting nervous just
remembering the feeling of having that
earbud with my ear let's do another
question all right this next question
comes from Jackie and it's a matter of
great importance Dear John and Hank for
Christmas I received several lush bath
bombs congratulations Jackie this seems
like a wonderful present except that I
don't have a bathtub I would give them
to my friends except none of them have
bathtubs what should I do with all these
baths baubau hand them out on the street
mail them to random addresses attempt a
bath bomb shower please help I don't
want these beautiful sparkly spheres to
go to waste
Sanae bye nice job Jackie we just made a
million dollars let me tell you why is
this something it is a bath bomb
compartment that let you clip on to the
in the a
between where your shower where your
shower connects to the wall your
showerhead connects to the wall and
where the showerhead is we can slip a
bath on there and then you our bath bomb
showers so you're just like basically
showering and I think this is some
sparkly water yeah yeah I think this is
no this is not something you know I mean
like I need to talk to an engineer about
how to develop a compartment that you
would put a bath bomb into hot water
rushes over it comes out of the shower
and you become the incredible glamorous
hole you know Hank over the years you've
presented me with million-dollar ideas
on I would guess conservatively 4,000
occasions by your math I should be a
billionaire now admittedly a few times
you have had a properly good idea
although I would just like to say for
the record that I would argue our best
idea ever
was mine you've had a few properly good
ideas this is not one of them so like
remember all those times when you would
feel exactly as excited as you feel
about this idea and turned out that
those were terrible ideas this is like
those times not like the few times when
you were right John I am going to be the
bigger man and on at least this idea
into the world I'm saying this is not
patented public domain it is your
responsibility listener to decide if you
are the person who is going to make this
a million dollar product and you're
gonna be on QVC and you're gonna be like
that crazy pillow guy being like pillows
are awful and I've got a better pal out
and also who's a huge fan of Donald
Trump for some reason and I I've no idea
who you're talking about but it's
fascinating just what I know about this
person is it makes me really want to
hang out with them at a cocktail party I
tell you a bath bomb story yes but first
I just I want to complete the process of
releasing the idea into the world your
job listener
is to create the bath bum partment the
bath bombardment the battle the shower
bombarding the shower bombardment yes
and clothes it's yeah I mean it's not a
million dollar name I'll tell you that
but it's close it's some pizza so the
other day uh Alice opened up the
compartment I have a four year old
daughter she opened up the compartment
underneath my sink and she said daddy
what are these and I said those are
those bath bombs I was like and she's
seen a bath bombs before like we've even
used a couple of them in her bath and
she always likes them a lot and she said
well why haven't and she knows that I
love them and she said why I haven't
some version of why haven't you used
these and I said oh well all of these
like they have glitter in them so like
when you let them into the bath they
like you know spread glitter all through
the bath and she looked up at me and she
just said sparkles and I was like yeah
sparkles and she was like I want the
sparkles so now we have we found a good
home for the sparkly bath bombs man
Alice is suddenly all in on bath bombs
it's nice it's nice if I whenever I have
something where I can really connect
with Alice about and like our shared
interest in really high quality bath
experiences has become that place Jackie
we do not have an answer for your
question um I don't know you're talking
about John I had an amazing answer for
us question okay right now if I forgot I
had already I literally already
forgotten about the shower bomb
compartment I mean I just googled it
John and it doesn't appear to be a way
to convert a shower into a bath bomb
experience I think that there is a huge
open market here for for bringing the
bath bomb experience into the huge
section of the world that does not have
the ability to use bath bombs we can
sound like they're on sale at lush next
Tuesday I swear to god it's gonna happen
yeah okay got Godspeed and and whoever
takes this on as a project I wish them
all of the luck in the world and they
will need it I got another question for
you it comes from
be who asks dear Hank and John there's
this guy I'm friends with and I like him
and he seems to like me and everything
is beautiful - nothing hurts right wrong
about a month ago he lent me a box of
ball bearings I'm just gonna leave out
why I'm gonna leave that part of the
question out because it's it's not even
very long but I would rather it just
build that you got lint a box of all
bears he's a very nice guy and he he's
very caring so he gave me the ball
bearing right but I have lost the ball
bearings now I'm desperate I what do I
do
do I come clean do I order some ball
bearings to his house and never speak
about it again do I change my identity
thanks in advance this is Abby I mean I
listen Abby you're gonna have some
challenges in this relationship there's
gonna be good times there's gonna be bad
times especially if it becomes a kind of
serious foundational romantic
relationship in your life and the ball
bearings thing you're not gonna look
back on it as the biggest problem you
you ever faced with this person but you
don't want to build the relationship on
a foundation of lies oh you can do say
like listen I lost the ball bearings if
you're gonna hang out with me that's
something you need to know about me is
that I lose stuff all the time
I I feel like I had to have that
conversation with Sarah very early on by
the way today I said to Sarah hey Sarah
I think we need more diapers for the dog
also can you call my phone I don't know
where it is and also I can't find my
keys and Sarah's response were the dog
diapers arrived this morning your phone
is in Henry's bed and your keys are on
the kitchen counter and I was like oh my
god what is it like to walk through the
universe knowing where things are
yesterday I was in my I went to the
office in part because I didn't know how
my computer was so I figured it I had
left it at the off you know I got there
it wasn't there and I was like I don't
know what my computer is and my
assistant said to me she you didn't
bring it in and I said to her no I did
and she said I don't know I don't know
but I watched you walk in and you
weren't holding your computer and I like
Mariann how did you how could you
possibly have a picture and
mind of what I was carrying when I
walked into the office but she was like
I think and I was like well it
definitely brought it and she was like
is it possible it's in the car and I was
like no no I looked and then it was in
the cup of course it was in the car it
so yeah I know it's very frustrating I
feel the same way I lose my glasses all
the time and then I'm like well now I'm
doubly screwed because I don't know how
to lose my glasses because they're
always on me well but like I don't know
I'll put them down I'll be cleaning them
or something and then I'll get
distracted and I'll walk away for three
seconds and then I'll turn them back
around and I'll be like oh no I can't
see anything to find my glasses there is
always that moment where you're like
like especially if it's if it's
nighttime and so it's dark and like I I
can't see how could I possibly find my
glasses in order to see what I can't see
it's just it's the struggle Jon but I
can't get LASIK because this is my brand
now that's the best reason not to get
LASIK I've ever heard I think I think
we've adequately answered that question
you got to tell about the ball bearings
issue just come clean or alternatively
like get some ball bearings on Amazon
and they'll be there in two days uh yeah
but also come clean do both I don't
think that you should just like fake
like you didn't well I don't know it
doesn't it's it's not gonna matter that
much actually this next question comes
from Kate who writes Dear John and Hank
my fiancé's mother recently gave me a
dress that no longer fits her
unfortunately it's the dress she wore to
her late husband's funeral
my fiance's father hmm well that was
weird yeah well I mean I like I can't
even imagine getting a dress for another
person at all because I feel like that's
a very personal decision like I watch
women shop for dresses and they look at
a lot of dresses that they do not buy
and so I feel like selecting one and
being like you will enjoy this dress is
just extremely presumptuous because
according to my view of the world 99.9%
of dresses are unacceptable yeah not
only that Hank I would actually extend
this
outside the world of dresses and say
that like if Sarah's family like gave me
a suit or even a shirt or a pair of
socks and was like you know these are
the these are the special funeral socks
I would I would feel very I would feel
the weight of them very intensely anyway
my fiance was surprisingly accepting at
this but I'm a little uncomfortable
wearing it around him and his family
it's a lot of pressure yeah I agree
plus it doesn't very well oh I mean this
not super shocking so I worry about the
formality of even wearing into funerals
I'm sorry to be laughing Kate but things
things are out of control here sometimes
we just have to do what people we love
need us to do so maybe I should get it
tailored to use it is it acceptable to
just keep it in my closet forever as you
are a podcast about death I figured you
were certified to attack the etiquette
of the situation hopefully nobody will
die in the interim Kate yeah I don't
think that you need to wear this this
dress to funerals right hard stop yeah
Kate and also everyone who's listening
who is transitioning from like their 20s
to their 30s here's what's about to
happen to you your parents yeah and or
your parents of your spouse or partner
are going to start to send you things
that you do not care about oh because
they are aware that they are going to
die and they are trying to get rid of
the things that they have a sentimental
attachment to and put it somewhere that
is not the trash right I mean what
they're saying is I got it please hold
on okay I have to stop you I have to
stop you I have to stop okay I said that
your parents are gonna send you things
that you don't care about and I just
want to say as someone who recognizes
that our parents listen to this podcast
iCare iCare mom it's Hank that doesn't
care I care a lot so I just want to say
that right now hey it doesn't care about
the stuff that you send him he doesn't
care I care I do especially about the
saying that I don't care I'm saying this
is what's going to happen to other
people who are
me and who very deeply appreciate all of
the things that I have received from my
mother that I have no context for me
okay I care I care mom I love everything
yeah and they love it the these the end
and what they are asking of you is
please hold on to this until I am dead
and then throw it away no that is not
what they are asking of you they are
asked we have to move on to the next
question because I feel that we are in
more dangerous territory than we've ever
entered before with our with our
arguably our most important listeners
since I don't think our spouses listen
Catherine totally Oh Sara doesn't I'm
not sure Sara's ever heard a full
episode of deer head good job yeah Oh
Catherine said avid listener Sheila oh
that's funny yeah listen still this week
in Ryan's she supports us on Sarah
listen to like the first 15 minutes of
an episode with me in the car one day
and she turned to me and she said I just
I guess maybe I don't get it whereas I
this week walked into my home and
Katherine was like John was giving you a
really hard time about Ryan this week
and I was like right right different
stroke yeah yeah no I mean just like it
just seems like being at dinner with the
two of you and I was like I think that
people like about it yeah that's kind of
the thing this next question comes from
Morgan who asks dear Hank and John how
do fish get into Lakes veni vidi vici
Morgan oh I know the answer to this well
there's lots of different answers but go
they get into lakes this is my
understanding at least from what I was
told by our parents when I was a kid
because they bird feet get fish eggs
stuck to them and then the birds go from
Lake to Lake populating new lakes with
fishes yeah that definitely happens that
is one of the ways in which it happens
for sure additionally I don't know if
you're aware of this but a certain storm
systems can actually
suck fish up into them in and drop them
other places that happens like you know
like every third Sunday or so what
there's a one no I'm just making that up
Oh God I mean I I was completely
convinced it does happen though I don't
know if that's one of the ways that that
that actually helps to distribute fish
but yeah I saw about this dogs yeah I
think it's like that
that's how sharks get into lakes I don't
dude man my kids are so afraid of river
River sharks yeah I'm about river sharks
well they are obsessed with this idea
that there are River sharks and that
there are sharks in the white river in
Indianapolis and I'm like well guys
there are no River sharks and then
immediately Henry's like dad I think we
both know that's an oversimplification
so don't try to condescend to me mister
because I have looked at the information
and there are sometimes sharks in some
areas of river ocean interaction that
are considered River yeah I mean well
also no one's ever seen a river shark
which just it makes it very clear that
these River sharks are made of glass
right it's much scarier oh man that's a
shout-out to my BIM BAM reference for
all you big my brother my brother and me
the idea once the idea is planted in
your brain that there may be a shark
there's a shark well and there are there
are sharks in some rivers it's just that
the white river in Indianapolis is not
one of those rivers and but then right
then immediately I mean it's almost like
trying to like trying to convince your
brain of something when your brain is
really really convinced that it wants to
worry about it because immediately
they'll both be like well if there are
sharks in some rivers how do we know
there aren't sharks in the white river
and I'm like guys it doesn't matter we
don't even get in the water it's filthy
like you don't know the real risk of
getting in the white river it's that the
microorganisms that definitely make you
severely ill well I do want to say John
that there are some species of
jerk that live entirely in freshwater
yes we're in both fresh and brackish
waters are not very many of them and
they are only in places that are not in
North America but they do exist River
sharks yes and then the other thing I
wanted to say is that most lakes are
connected to each other by rivers and
streams and stuff so true and yeah yeah
yep almost every lake eventually ends up
in the ocean the exceptions are the ones
that are salty like the Great Salt Lake
does not drain to an ocean which is why
it is salty because the salt can't get
out to the ocean
it builds up at the Great Salt Lake the
Dead Sea also you know like any any salt
lake is a like that doesn't drain to the
ocean but almost every lake eventually
ends up in the ocean but sometimes there
are like barriers like it filters
through like it might go underground and
a fish could not make that route or the
streams might be too small for certain
species of fish to go up and and and
there are a number of ways that that
fish move around sometimes they are
accidentally introduced by people both
like releasing pets or they get in the
bilge compartments of boats that move
from place to place and they will move
around that way but yeah there's there's
a bunch of different ways but it does
happen and over the they basically
there's a long period of time during
which this can have happened and so it
it ends up happening because you know
geology is on a very long time scale and
once a fish gets introduced someplace
especially if there's more than one then
you they're just there forever
mmm-hmm well now we know are they there
forever or do they eventually die they
eventually die John okay I'm sorry I was
just reading about River sharks well
good the good news is John that someday
there will be no River sharks left to
even remember that River sharks existed
it's such a it's it's such a good point
the oceans will boil and all record of
us will be forgotten yep and all the
river sharks will never ever eat a
single a single four-year-old ever again
okay all right let's move on to another
question this one comes from
who writes Dear John and Hank every once
in a while I upload a new profile
picture to Facebook and every time I do
people comment on my picture things like
heart emojis and looking great or stuff
like that and I never know what to say
am I supposed to say thank you if so
what is the proper way to thank a person
who left you three heart emojis am I
allowed to respond with a heart emoji
back or must I have a message in plain
English please help I have no idea what
the etiquette is and I just posted a
profile picture yesterday perpetually
confused
Katie Katie I have I have recently come
across the best possible solution to
this problem which is that you're going
to need to call your mom or dad or loved
one and have them go on and respond to
these comments well let's thank you so
you have your mom go on and say when
someone says looking great your mom then
goes on and says thank you because your
mom is what made you one too you will
also be reminding these people that your
mom is watching and so to behave
correctly oh that's a good and and three
that you will not have to do anything
because your mom will be your mom will
be basking in the glory of people
thinking highly of her progeny and and
that will become the more important
story okay I mean that's not a bad idea
but I have a better idea which is
something that I've done in my own life
Katie and I highly recommend to you but
first you have to become old
so that's the first key but the good
thing about one of the great things
about being old is that you are not
expected to use emojis so whenever
somebody sends me an emoji and I really
feel compelled to reply I reply with a
little less than a key and then the
number three which is how we
communicated heart emojis pre emoji and
that's just my way of reminding people
like eh I'm old and be like this is this
is my preferred method of communication
like I don't like this visual language
this pictographic language I still I
still like it to be as text-based as
possible
so that's what I would do I would reply
with a less than three mm-hmm I do
less than three is allowed myself I
probably would not reply with less than
three because I don't want it and I want
to like give off too much of like I
don't want to think people are flirting
with like I'm flirting with them about
my cute new profile pic I want people to
be aware that I'm a married man and that
this is not about not about escalating
any any friendship that we have to a new
level and so I reply instead with just a
picture of a can of Diet Dr Pepper it's
a bold choice it's a bold choice
I was recently texting with a friend of
mine now you know how now predictive
texting when you type a word it will
show you the emoji for that word yeah
yeah I think you yeah you wanna you want
to say bread instead you want to show a
picture of prey what would be way better
right when we've got bread right here
anyway I don't I don't like it at all
but I was apps I'm regularly stunned by
what is available in terms of in terms
of emojis and the other day I was
texting with my friend Shannon and she
said do you want to go curling at this
bar downtown and I replied I think I'm
gonna pass on curling holy crap there is
a curling emoji which there is and I was
like part of the text that you sent yeah
that's the I was just reading you the
actual text oh okay there's a curling
emoji so there you go I mean just when
you think that winter sucks out comes
the curling emoji to cheer you right up
which reminds me that today's podcast is
brought to you by the emoji movie the
emoji oh my god no I have seen it
podcast is also brought to you by the
Writers Guild of America the Writers
Guild of America it's doing something
but also making it so that John can't
send me his movie screeners I just want
to say for the record that the Writers
Guild of America is doing a great job
genuinely of making sure that its
members have lots of things that we
would not have if it were not for
collective bargaining okay moving on
past the political though today's blog
is also brought to you by airplane
earbuds airplane earbuds it's a great
life hack and of course this podcast is
brought to you by the
bath bombardment compartment was good
did that better was that a good one I've
it's unbearable but available for you to
create and sell to Lush Cosmetics to
open up the world of bath bombs to the
rest of us yeah I'm still not convinced
tank but I appreciate your excitement we
also have a real sponsor today it's our
friends at audible John right now I am
listening to a Michael Connelly book on
audible I actually found a three pack
with just one credit I got three Michael
Connelly books which include two what
two of them that I actually really
wanted to read so or listened to and
I've been enjoying it greatly maybe a
little bit too much they're kind of
they're pretty suspenseful and I end up
getting sucked in and maybe laying in
bed for a little longer than I should
before I fall asleep so that is not the
greatest endorsement but I guess it is
good content anyway I've been listening
to the dawn watch this amazing biography
of Joseph Conrad on audible and it's
really really good I highly recommend it
you can also just for the record get my
books my Turtles all the way down is
narrated by the brilliant Kate Rudd as
is my book The Fault in Our Stars today
by the way I think it's the six year
anniversary of the publication of my
book The Fault in Our Stars so yeah you
can get lots and lots of different books
on audible it's a really it's a really
great service and you can also get your
first month free with a free audiobook
you get a 30 day trial and one free
audiobook if you go to audible.com slash
Dear John or audible.com slash dear Hank
and if you can also if you want to get
that deal by texting dear Hank or Dear
John to 500 500 so that'll that'll yeah
you could send a text message and that
will get you going with audible I have
not heard about that thing yet but yeah
that is really cool that is great yeah
yeah you can text 500 500 dear Hank or
Dear John and get that same deal audible
really is in my opinion an amazing value
I I haven't found in my life that
audiobooks have replaced print books but
they have been are now a addition to
print books in my life and yeah there's
great also there's really good audible
only
cast so check it out audible.com slash
Dear John or to a much lesser extent
audible.com slash dear Hank
or text dear Hank to 500 500
or to a much lesser extent Dear John and
I just want to thank audible for being a
great supporter of podcasts as well so
thanks for supporting a lot of the
podcasts that I like and also for
supporting this podcast all right I
think this question comes from Sarah who
writes dear John and Hank how do I stay
aware of what's happening in the YouTube
community without contributing views and
publicity to the terrible things that
happen and that I don't want to support
I usually have either already clicked or
I hear about it from someone and to
understand it I go and watch and that
feels like casting a vote in favor
before I even know what I'm voting on
help trying not to increase worldsuck
Sarah that has a tension that we have
both in the YouTube community and also
just sort of the larger world like
sometimes I feel like well I have to
stay informed of terrible things and so
do I like am i required to kind of hate
watch stuff am i required to be
subscribed to people who have views that
I dislike and who are actively having an
intentionally having a negative impact
on the world just so I can keep up and
and help when things go extra wrong and
I actually traced the how the logan paul
like logan paul's video was on youtube
for a full 24 hours before anybody
started saying negative things about it
and i like found the person who I heard
it from and I was like who did you hear
this from and trace it all the way back
to somebody who yes watched watches
logan paul because they hate him and and
recognizes that that is an unproductive
and bad thing to do with their time and
Wow
but like then texted the video to a
friend and was like well this is really
and then that person texted it to
another person who then put it like sort
of a note on Twitter and then somebody
asked that person about that and that
person had you know 4 million followers
so that's how it got out and it's sort
of amazing that because like you know
there are so many different sort of like
silos to content experience on the
internet that something like that can be
out there for a long time and have 6
million views on it before anybody who
you know is going to be even vaguely
critical starts
see it which is rockin yeah I mean
that's that that's an interesting
observation and I I don't really know
what to do about this problem it's one
of many problems of the social Internet
that I don't really know what to do
about right now and I feel even though I
know I have like tremendous power and
and a huge platform I still feel very
powerless in the face of it I don't I
don't I I think some of these problems
are some of these problems go all the
way back right like I mean there was
YouTube they were channels devoted to
YouTube drama when Hank and I first
started making videos in January of 2007
you know it's it's had its own sort of
ecosystem that whole time I I don't
think that I and and I don't know I mean
a lot of times the things that people
are outraged about in fact usually the
things that people are outraged about
are truly infuriating and they are
outrageous and they are reprehensible
but then there is always some new
equally reprehensible outrage of
tomorrow and I don't know what my level
of requirement is when it comes to
knowing about those outrages because I
also know there are lots of outrages
that I don't pay attention to admittedly
the world of YouTube is closed to me and
it matters a lot to me
and it feels like my world in a way that
other worlds don't but I also know that
you know I ought to be paying better
attention to outrages that are happening
on a global scale and where attention to
those outrages really does move the
needle and really does require people
you know really can I think
lead people to action I I think you know
we see that when a famine is declared
for instance like the moment of famine
is declared the world starts paying
attention in a way that it doesn't when
famine is merely a risk or when the UN
is saying famine could be coming to
Somalia it's the world treats that very
differently than the moment when it's
announced well famine has come and I
think I just I I don't I don't know what
my I don't know
how much I need to swim in the river on
a daily basis the like the huge river of
information that we're all swimming in I
don't know how much of it I need to swim
in in a daily basis in order to be like
a good citizen of the internet and I
wish I had a good answer for the
question yeah I mean in general I feel
like maybe we we've err on the side of
too much in general or I do
mm-hm and that but what what sort of
ends up happening is because there's
always the fresh outrage it you know it
it makes it very difficult for things
that are persistent problems that need
to be handled but aren't having like a
big you know newsworthy thing part of
them and makes it very difficult for
those things to break into my
consciousness and awareness when I'm
tired of like so caught up and whatever
the fresh outrage is and actually
YouTube isn't pretty good example of
that because we all know that these
problems existed before that particular
logan paul video was uploaded that one
was particularly yeah particularly
outrageous and particularly horrifying
but we all know that like that wasn't
the beginning of the problems on the
social internet or the beginnings of the
problems within certain youtube
communities yeah and Menaul so like i
think that it like it problems like you
know a lot of puerto rico is still not
having power back like those are right
like we knew that that was going to be a
thing and it is it is playing out and it
is happening and it is just it can't
break back into the news cycle because
it didn't just happen
and because right oh like it's ain't an
incremental problem where it's like we
need to get power back to the next
neighborhood and the next neighborhood
and like there are certain problems that
it feels like the internet is bad at not
at at just addressing but at even at the
base level making people aware of and
and i think the only way to sort of push
back against that as a consumer of
content is to say like maybe the fresh
outrage isn't as important as something
else that's going on maybe i need to
like be stepping back a little bit and
not completely desensitizing myself to
you know to the sort of injustice and
yeah
right to systemic long-term injustice
this is something that Hank and I talk a
lot about in in private especially
trying to think about you know where we
want the emphasis of our personal
philanthropy to be people are really
good at responding to emergencies and
and thank thank God they are because we
have to respond to a lot of emergencies
and I think people are and I think the
Internet is actually quite good at
responding to emergencies I think where
where people struggle and the internet
may be exaggerated s' this this problem
is we really struggle with long term
solutions to long term problems we
really struggle with the idea that you
know some some interventions are going
to take decades not hours and there are
some problems that can be solved that
will be solved if we focus our attention
on them for a long time that can't be
solved quickly I think sometimes we have
successes on that front I mean where you
are about to experience the end of polio
which is only the second time that a
disease has been eradicated from human
beings by force of science and and by
force of people coming together and
working incredibly hard to make that
happen and and that required a really or
still requires a really long term vision
for making it for making that happen but
I yeah we struggle with this as a
species I think and we see it with
climate change we also see it with
things like making long-term investments
in healthcare systems in the developing
world John before we get to the news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon I have one
response that's not a question from Kate
who says hi I'm Kate and I am one of
Nicole's emergency replacement pen pals
and I just want to say it's been amazing
to have her as a pen pal and would like
to thank you guys for connecting us as
well as Nicole for being great pen pal
thanks you guys that's very nice that's
great that's got also ink yeah
rosianna emphasised this last week I
think it's amazing this one comes from
Hadley he writes I was listening to the
episode every plum has its thorn and you
guys read a comment about a girl named
Sierra who lives in a dorm where a snake
was on the loose I also live in that
dorm
on the fourth floor of Centennial Hall
and I've actually met the snake before
he was lost his name is Archie and he is
a ball python about two feet long and
he's very nice then also also I got a
letter from Gwynn and they wrote so I'm
listening to your 120 first episode
literally right now and realized when
you were talking about the snake listen
Sierra's dorm that you guys were talking
about my farm I told my girlfriend about
this because it was so surreal and she
said she'd read about it on our
University's subreddit yes our
university has a subreddit thankfully
the snake was found though hungry and
lethargic and has recovered thank you
for that update
Gwyn and thanks to everybody in
Centennial Hall and beyond enjoying I
just I really hope that symp like that
we can just become the official podcast
of Centennial Hall maybe maybe we will
avoid Centennial Hall if you're looking
to sponsor us you can contact us right
now what if what if we happy to have you
a Centennial Hall exclusive episode of
dear Hank and John where it's only
question I'm in doing I love that one
anyway
brilliant John what is the news from AFC
Wimbledon well Hank AFC Wimbledon played
their big money FA Cup 3rd round game
against Tottenham Hotspur there at
Wembley you'll remember that AFC
Wimbledon completely undefeated it at
Wembley never lost a game at Wembley
until January the 7th 2018 it was an
incredible first 62 minutes AFC
Wimbledon held Tottenham scoreless for
62 mile in enduring something like 87
percent
possession for Tottenham and
astonishingly AFC Wimbledon hit the bar
they hit the bow in a shot in the first
half and if that if that had gone in who
knows what would have happened taught
them to be fair also hit the post a few
times and then in the 63rd minute Harry
Kane one of the best strikers in the
world scored a goal
he didn't scored another goal in the
65th minute and Wimbledon ended up
losing three nil but the guys at nine
years podcast the podcast about AFC
Wimbledon summarized it their three word
summary of the match was heads held
hi and I think that was a good summary
indeed this Saturday January 13th which
will be in the past as this is uh as
this is uploaded AFC Wimbledon will be
playing a game that is of a significant
import to their league one season and
also of significant import generally
because they will be playing the
franchise currently applying its trade
in Milton Keynes which for those of you
familiar with AFC Wimbledon's history
will know is is you know it's a big game
the franchise currently applying a trade
Milton Keynes is 19th in Ligue 1 and
Wimbledon are 21st
if Wimbledon were to win that game
Wimbledon would be out of the relegation
zone and also possibly Milton Keynes
would be in the relegation zone of
course the dream scenario Hank and
obviously you can't football isn't made
out of dreams but the dream scenario is
that Wimbledon stays in Ligue 1 Milton
Keynes does not so that that is a
fixture that will hopefully like never
happen again because it is one that
never should happen and yeah we'll see
how that goes down well John that is
exciting and I'm glad that you guys made
a bunch of money because that's the what
really matters well it will hopefully
help us pick up at least one player in
January which will be especially useful
since one of our strikers just had
surgery on his hamstring ie well
nyeeehhh
just not fun pay for that surgery except
they don't have to because it's free cuz
it's England in in Mars news John you
probably you may have heard that around
the turn of the year a few days ago some
the Curiosity rover spotted some weird
structures on the surface of some
sedimentary rocks that looked for all
the world like what might happen if like
us a worm or something crawled through
some some dirt or sand and left a tube
behind and then that tube then got
filled up with a harder sediment over
over time and that would have been some
kind of fossilized worm tube basically
and we've seen things like this on earth
that you find these sort of
holes left by invertebrates getting
fossilized and and people are like well
okay stop everything and so the day they
stopped everything and they got a much
closer up picture of these weird
fossilized worm tube looking things and
the news is in John they're not
fossilized worm tubes probably oh that's
disappointing I was hoping for huge Mars
worms they would be it would have been
very small Mars worms but it was it took
it took about it took about thirty
minutes for all the reputable places to
be like wait now so the the sitch is
that they look like they are some kind
of pretty interesting crystalline
structures that are again almost
definitely what it did sort of happen
this way where the crystals grew the
sedimentary rock then formed around the
crystals then the crystals dissolved and
then more sedimentary rock came in and
so this is a process that would have
required there to be multiple cycles of
water probably hot water coming in and
out of of this system which is you know
pretty pretty standard now amazingly for
for the lake bed where the Curiosity
rover is hanging out that we know that
there was a lot of water in a lot of
different ways a lot of different times
and but yeah so close up they look to be
much more angular than they did when
there was a more distant shot and so
they're thinking probably crystal molds
and molds not being microorganism molds
but molds mo LDS I don't know how you
spell wait how do you spell mold it's
the same both ways it's the English
language is confusing you know what I
mean I think it might be different in
England right maybe that's what I'm
thinking so that but like it's it's
worth noting that like this was so
interesting that they actually backed
the rover up to go take the closer
picture so they had this picture and
they were like what is that and they
actually turned like they reversed
curiosity to go back and take that that
closer up picture so that's really cool
that is cool but it turned out it was
not it was not it was like not a complex
life for him but it was cool
geochemistry happening
right right oh that's I mean yeah I'm
excited about geochemistry I'd be more
excited if we had some Mars worms but I
know I've got to be patient and etc yeah
I mean the curiosity's mission is not to
find Mars worms it's to study the
geology of Mars which it is doing and
wonderful successful ways all right I'll
accept that but we need to find those
Mars worm soon because we need well I
don't actually know if we need to find
Mars worms we need to find we need to
give people on Mars setting up an
alternate social order soon part yeah
all right well but not too soon because
you want the podcast name to change
right yeah I mean at this point I might
even be willing to sacrifice that I
don't know it's a pretty big deal to be
though that this podcast you're John and
Hank in the future Hank what did we
learn today oh god we learned that we
are all bathed in a soup of gases that
transmits sound waves to you and that is
probably also true for all the space
aliens we learned that Lady Bird is
John's favorite movie of the year so far
I haven't seen all of them yet
we learned that ear buds are your best
friend when you're in public and do not
want to be bothered
we learned that you're alone in the
universe I mean I'm not alone in the
universe there's so many different
humans I can hang out with and also dogs
guys that's it why are you stopping
there why not River sharks so I don't
want to hang out with River sharks I
mean I don't know do I
are they nice I'm not sure I don't know
oh yeah I'm sure I could tell you I
think he knows everything about them
all right John thank you for having a
podcast with me and thank you to
everyone for listening we're about to go
record our patron only podcast this week
in Ryan's if you want to support us at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
that would be much appreciated we do
cool stuff with that money like makes a
show and crash course and also we will
probably put up you know we tend to put
up also like sort of show notes kind of
things like if we have any pictures we
want to share with you and put those up
and those are not only for patrons so
you can also use the patreon even if you
aren't a patron so thank you but thank
you to audible for your sponsorship and
for also making it easy for me to enjoy
lots of different audiobooks this
podcast is produced by rosianna halse
rojas and shared in gibson it's edited
by nicholas jenkins our head of
community and communications is victoria
bon giorno the theme music that you hear
at the beginning and right now is by the
great gunnarolla he also does the intro
music for this week in Ryan's and as
they say in our hometown don't forget
the URLs
[Music]